what's up
good afternoon everybody
welcome back from
your Thanksgiving holiday hope everyone
had a restful
and uh wonderful holiday okay I'm going
to be really quick at the top as you see
we have a guest as you know we have a
guest uh from National Security Council
John Kirby with us today who's going to
take your questions ahead of the state
visit as you know that it will be
happening uh on Thursday our first date
visited with France and
first state visit clearly with the in
this Administration so with that I'm
going to just start right away and turn
it over to Kirby all right John thank
you so much across
as Korean said I've just got a couple of
comments here at the top about the state
visit as the first state visit of the
Biden Harris Administration
this is an opportunity to highlight a
foundational component of this
administration's approach to foreign
policy and that's through alliances
France is a vital Global partner and of
course United States is oldest Ally
our economic ties span established in
cutting-edge sectors with major
investments in both directions
supporting hundreds of thousands of jobs
in each country our defense and security
cooperation continues to expand and of
course is vital to peace and stability
all around the world
our partnership in tackling tough Global
challenges underpinned by our shared
commitment to democratic principles
values and institutions
and our cultural ties remain a source of
strength and importance to our bilateral
relationship France remains as you know
a top destination for many Americans and
vice versa
so just briefly on the schedule
breakdown on Wednesday president macron
will join vice president Harris in
visiting NASA headquarters to showcase
our deepening collaboration on space in
support of Earth climate and space
science and space exploration
the bulk of the state visit
events will take place on Thursday
starting with the official arrival
ceremony well then while President Biden
and president macron conduct a bilateral
discussion
there will be a separate program for the
first lady and Mrs macron in the
afternoon the vice president and
secretary blinken will host a luncheon
at the state department in honor of
President and Mrs macron and then of
course the visit culminates in the state
dinner here at the White House that
evening
throughout all of these events you can
expect you can expect to see on display
both our long shared history as allies
as well as our deep partnership and
taking on the most urgent Global
challenges of today and tomorrow
we anticipate that we'll have more to
share about the details of the state
dinner and the guest list later this
week while there are specific areas
where we anticipate will make progress
during this visit I want to stress that
this visit really largely serves as a
celebration of the strong footing of
this relationship one that is well
rooted in our history from the very
beginnings of our country and while also
oriented squarely toward the future and
it's a very Dynamic exciting feature
that we're looking forward to well that
take some questions
yeah um so John I wonder if you could
just say a few words about why France
was chosen for the first state visit
they sort of talked about the historic
ties but is this also kind of um you
know a gesture in terms of making making
the relationship a little smoother after
the August of last year I kind of
alluded to it in the answer Andrea a
real
kind of the long pull in the tent for
President Biden's approach to foreign
policy and and to the world around us is
the is the strength and power of
alliances and our alliances is something
that no other nation in the world can
match in that work of American alliances
France is our oldest one uh and I mean
if you look at
what's going on in Ukraine look at
what's going on in the indo-pacific and
the tensions with China France is really
at the center of all those things uh and
president macron has been a dynamic
leader inside the G7 uh particularly uh
there in Europe uh and so the president
felt that this was exactly the the right
and the most appropriate country to
start with for State visits
are the EV credits in the inflation
reduction act this is an issue I mean I
realized the way the EU is structured
you know the EU Brussels who's in
Georgia trade policy do you expect that
issue to come up do you think there's
any chance of resolving that short of a
WTO
um you know dispute I think certainly
that the issue will most likely come up
I think we look forward to having that
discussion uh with our French
counterparts as you know last month the
United States stood up helped stood up
stand up a uh an EU us Ira task force
just last month to try to make sure that
we can better understand the concerns of
our European friends about this and so
many other issues
um the bottom line for us is first of
all we want to understand the concerns
we're absolutely willing to have that
conversation uh and to and to find a way
to work through those issues of concern
but it's not a zero-sum game I mean
clean energy that that's a tie that
right that raises all boats uh the more
we can transition to a clean energy
economy around the world uh and there's
plenty of opportunity for everybody in
that so we're looking forward to having
those discussions
uh John a different topic I was hoping
uh what is the White House's message the
president's message to people in China
who are peaceably protesting covered
lockdowns there and then did the topic
of China's zero code policy come up in
the presence by a lot of women meeting
with President XI when they met in
Indonesia a couple weeks ago they did
talk about covid and the effect that the
pandemic had had around the world
clearly that came up inside the the
conversation I don't know if
specifically the zero uh covid policy
was an issue of discussion but certainly
covet was on the agenda as you might
expect that it would be
um and our our message to Peaceful
protesters around the world uh is the
same and and consistent people should be
allowed uh uh the the right to assemble
and to peacefully protest policies or
laws or dictates that that they take
issue with does the White House support
their efforts to sort of regain their
personal freedoms and why do these
lockdowns the White House supports the
right of peaceful protest and then on a
different topic the state department I'd
say that Russia abruptly canceled uh the
latest rounds of arms negotiations
um is the present plan to reach out to
uh to anybody about that is there any
White House reaction to that I don't
have any phone calls or conversations
stations to read out what you're talking
about is the bilateral consultative
commission and this is a component of
the new start treaty that was
signed on to in 2010 this is a it's
basically an opportunity for both sides
to get together and talk about the
technicalities the formalities the
compliance mechanisms that are in place
with respect to new start this would
this would have been the first one that
we would have put in put in place since
covid which obviously prevented those
kinds of face-to-face meetings so we
very much were looking forward to
starting supposed to start tomorrow and
we were very much looking forward to
that because we continue to believe in
the importance of a new start we haven't
got uh haven't received excuse me
a real solid answer from the Russians as
to why they postponed this we're going
to be working through the embassy to try
to figure out what happened here and
we'd like to see it get back on the
schedule as soon as possible because
it's important it's not just important
for our two Nations it's important for
the rest
thank you Karin
um two questions uh John uh first the
niece of the Ayatollah Khomeini was
arrested uh in Tehran recently as part
of the protest March does the
administration having stated its support
for peaceful protests have any
particular statement about her arrest we
would I think say stay very consistent
sir that we believe in the right of
peaceful protest we have made it clear
that we stand with uh particularly it's
largely Iranian women but it's obviously
beyond that but particularly their
concerns about
about the dictates that have affected
their lives personally and will continue
to do whatever we can to not only
support their right of protest but to
hold the regime accountable for the way
it's treating its people and along the
same lines is the administration going
to put out a statement to the military
Junta in Burma about the published
report
of the incarceration and keeping
incommunicado the former leader ansung
Sushi I I don't have a preview of some
sort of statement to read out to you
today we've been very clear about our
concerns over uh over uh the military's
domination there uh and their practice
and their policies uh particularly the
way they treat political prisoners but I
don't have a statement for you today
about that particular issue
is it the US's assessment that these
protests we've seen are widespread or
are they perhaps more isolated incidents
that are being Amplified by social media
I don't think that we know a whole lot
more about the geographic location size
scale and scope of them than what you're
learning as well through social media
and through traditional media it's not
like we have I think
um a finer sense of insight than than
what's already out there in the public
sphere
um so I I you know I don't I don't have
a sense of that in that
statement you
harming protesters and journalists
we're watching this closely as you might
expect we would and again we continue to
stand up and support the right of
peaceful protest and I think we're going
to watch this closely and we'll see
where things go put on Iran for the U.S
men's national soccer team yeah uh has
thrown up an image of the Old Flag
before then including the Islamic
Republic symbol
um was the uh does the White House have
any comment on that decision no actually
we don't and this isn't the kind of
thing that you would that the White
House would comment on a USA soccer is a
private entity and they uh they make
their own decisions about those kinds of
things and we wouldn't uh we wouldn't
comment on that we wish them all the
best tomorrow the team that said it was
cons it changed the flag after
consultations
with various entities afterward are you
aware of anyone in the US government
speaking to the team of matter where
many conversations by anybody in the U.S
government that had anything to do with
their decision either to
post that image
previously and then to to take it down
and replace it now
sort of risk to the U.S economy or the
U.S supply chain because of the protests
we don't see any
particular impact right now to the
supply chain as a result of these
protests and
then we have not offered any to to China
at this time as you know we are the
largest supplier of covid vaccines
around the world uh and we have not
received any requests or any interest by
China to receive our vaccines thank you
very much uh thank you John again on
China
um you you just noted that you're
watching this closely as we might expect
could you give us a sense of how much
the president is engaging with this
issue is he watching it personally you
know getting updated more than on maybe
some other things president staying
briefed on the uh on what's going on
inside China yes mostly brief promise
I've never been in the room where he
wasn't like yeah closely briefed I mean
yeah he's he's staying atop on what's uh
what's going on he's monitoring this we
all are um so yes the president is is
certainly staying mindful of the protest
activity okay thank you
thanks sweetie uh thank you John
um you know I sort of assume that the
United States supports peaceful protests
around the world that with all due
respect doesn't strike I would think
most people is a novel position the
question is well I'm glad that it's not
a novel position that's exactly where we
should be
but the president has explicitly drawn a
contrast between autocracy and democracy
here and also abroad isn't this a moment
obviously without getting into some sort
of grand conflict to
sort of assert the rights of people
advocating for freedom and democracy
more forcefully than perhaps we have
is a I think a moment
to reassert what uh what we believe in
when it comes to free assembly and
um and peaceful protest and we've done
that and we'll continue to do that
whether it's the people protesting in
Iran or China or anywhere else around
the world
um but nothing's changed about the the
president's firm belief in the power of
democracy and Democratic institutions
and how important that is but this is
really a moment to put it back into your
words this is a moment for uh you know
for the for the Chinese people and the
Chinese government to speak to we have
been nothing but clear and consistent
and I think you'll see that going
forward
so just a follow-up John on the China
issue why is the White House's line that
everybody has the right to peacefully
protest and not the US thinks it's bad
to a lot of people up in their houses to
stop cope we've we've made it clear
Peter that uh a uh a lockdown is is not
a policy that that we're going to
support here we've we've come a long way
over these last three years hard to
believe three years in terms of treating
covid and preventing covid so we've said
you know a lockdown is not a policy that
we support here
um
but obviously there are people in China
that that have have concerns about that
and they're protesting that and we
believe they should be able to do that
peacefully okay and on the sanctions
relief for Venezuela yeah why is it that
President Biden would rather let U.S
companies drill for oil in Venezuela
than here in the U.S
that's uh not an accurate take on the
president's view earlier this month he
said no more drilling there is no more
drilling the president has issued 9 000
permits for drilling on U.S federal
lands Peter 9 000 of them being unused
there are plenty of opportunities for
oil and gas companies to drill here in
the United States I'll let Chevron speak
for this particular issue of sanctions
relief but our expectation is it won't
be a lot of oil coming out of there
it'll have to be shipped to the United
States does the president think there's
some benefit to The Climate to drill oil
in Venezuela and not here it has nothing
to do with the benefits of the climate
Peter again there are 9 000 unused
permits here in the United States on
Federal Land that oil and gas companies
can and should take advantage of nine
thousand and we're talking about one
there in Venezuela now look it remains
to be seen how much we'll get drilled
down there
um it'll be up to Chevron to decide that
Peter
um but uh but as a function of the
sanction it's self that oil whatever
product is drilled has to come to the
United States
strategy that these restrictions may be
inhibiting the economic recovery
globally and here at home the president
believes and he's just said this many
times I mean covet absolutely has had an
impact on the global economy
um certainly it's had an impact on
Supply chains and resources around the
world
um and that's why the president wants to
move the United States as as quickly and
as efficiently as we can through uh
kovid so that so they even our economy
can get more on track than it already is
becoming now
um so I mean it is having a global
effect but what is also having a very
acute significant Global impact on the
economy is the war in Ukraine and that's
why we're trying to go after a price cap
on Russian oil that's why we're trying
to give Ukraine the tools and
capabilities they need to succeed on the
battlefield so this this war can end it
can end in a way in which uh uh Ukraine
can be whole and Sovereign and free so
there's a there's a lot of impacts on
the global economy it's not just about
covet but beyond just covet generally
does he think that China's zero covid
strategy that these restrictions are
inhibiting the economic recovery the
president recognizes that uh in many
countries around the world covet is
still an issue and certainly to the
degree that it inhibits a country's
ability to conduct Commerce it's having
an impact uh on the world and China is a
huge uh economic competitor out there
but I wouldn't get into Parson the the
dollar figure effect here of the of the
the remaining challenge of covid in
China but clearly China has a major
economic player and China still
struggling with uh covid there's
obviously there's an impact on the
economy and just one more on Paul Whelan
his brother said he missed a scheduled
phone call home to his family on
Thursday which they say is incredibly
unusual for him to miss a call
especially on a holiday like that uh how
concerned are you about this silence if
you received any information on his
condition and just can you give us any
update on any progress I don't have an
update for you this is the first I've
heard that there was a phone call that
was missed so why don't you let me take
that back and see if we can find out
something for you I don't want to just
speculate up here well obviously we're
deeply concerned about him and uh and
Brittany Greiner and all Americans
wrongfully detained overseas but let me
take that question
thank you uh two quick questions uh one
on China and then on Ukraine
I'm wondering what is the president's
reaction when he hears protesters in
China chant Freedom or Xi Jinping step
down the president is not going to speak
for protesters around the world they're
speaking for themselves
and so there's no reaction these
protesters are speaking for themselves
what we are doing is making it clear
that we support the right of peaceful
protest and then my follow-up
um
is the backlog of armed shipments to
Taiwan a result of our stepped up
efforts to send arms to Ukraine what I
can tell you is that we are constantly
balancing as we must our own inventories
the inventories of our allies and
partners and people that we do conduct
arms sales with as well as of course the
inventory that the Ukrainian Armed
Forces need to fight the Russian
aggression and it's a balancing act and
and with every single decision by the
president to draw down DOD stocks you
know he gets an assessment from the
Pentagon about whether that's going to
affect our Readiness and we're in
constant touch with again allies and
partners about their Readiness needs
because many of them are reliant on U.S
systems uh and of course you know that
includes Taiwan we just the president
just signed out what a month or so ago
another billion dollars of Taiwan arms
sales and of course we're going to
continue to look at what the the next
iteration of that needs to look like and
when that would occur but we take very
seriously our responsibility to help
provide Taiwan the self-defense
capabilities that's that it needs that's
in accordance with law and policy and
that's not going to change but in terms
of those shipments actually going out
the door to Taiwan currently is there a
backlog when it comes to those arms
being shut up I'm not going to get into
at a public Podium talking about uh
inventory stocks of any system anywhere
that just is not a good idea for uh for
us to do certainly not from the podium
we watch it very closely we make sure
that our Readiness can be preserved as
well as the Readiness of our allies and
partners but look has has all the
provisions to Ukraine has that has that
that caused an effort inside the
administration to make sure that we are
that we are judiciously monitoring
stocks and inventories and working with
the defense industry to plus them up and
to make sure that those Supply chains
are still flowing absolutely they have
of course of course we are but it's a
balance we strike every day sir yeah way
in the back
in Turkey
many are skeptical regarding the Turkish
claims that the pkp was behind the
explosion and Istanbul and now they are
using this as a justification for a
ground operation in Syria yeah did they
ask ask for an Evidence or did you offer
help for the investigation
do you see this as a proper
justification for a ground operations
I don't believe we've uh
we're offered anything to help with the
investigation and we're not in a
position to
um to say specifically who was
responsible we condemned the violence at
the time we condemn it today and as I've
said as recently as a week or so ago we
do need to remember that turkey
continues to be to fall victim to
terrorist attacks whether it's near that
border or elsewhere in inside the
country
and they have a right to
to defend themselves and their citizens
against attacks now what we've said
additionally is that we want to see the
tensions de-escalate here and we don't
want to see any actions
that a
lead to the potential of
additional casualties particularly
civilian casualties and B do anything
that would harm our efforts to continue
to work with our Syrian counterparts
against Isis which remains a viable
credible threat inside Iraq and Syria
and we got to keep the pressure on them
but is this echidine live for erdogan to
to go inside Syria when you say they
they have that right to defend
themselves they do have the right to
defend themselves they they have they
have they have suffered terrorist
attacks but we don't want to see uh
actions
particularly inside Syria that are going
to lead to potential for more casualties
more loss of innocent life and any
diminution of our efforts a distraction
away from our efforts because we have
troops in Syria that that to go after to
Isis the other thing I would uh I'd
mention is we also don't want to see any
actions inside Syria by turkey or anyone
one else that could put American lives
at risk because there are Americans on
the ground and they're helping the SDF
um
moving the relationship board in terms
of bilateral basis after the meeting
between President Biden and she Frank is
there any concern or will that those
steps have any effect on how the U.S
responds to any Chinese response to the
protests at a current time I think we're
going to have to watch this going
forward Phil uh what I can tell you is
as you and I are talking today there's
there's there's been no change to
uh our desire to continue to see these
channels of communication stay open and
we were heartened coming away from the
G20 that both leaders were able to agree
on getting some of these working level
discussions back open and so we're still
in that mode Phil where we want to
continue to get those uh get those
discussions uh uh back up and play and
as for whether or not there'll be an
impact from the protest we're just going
to have to I think we're just as I said
we're going to watch this and see where
it goes one more quickly apologize
um what kind of a crunch time for the
price cap you mentioned in a few minutes
ago yeah is there a sense inside the
White House right now that the president
or the team will need to have
more of a public posture in terms of
trying to get this across the Finish
Line I know it's kind of a new level
issue right now but yeah I don't think
well I don't think we're at that point
right now where we feel there's some
sort of inordinate pressure to uh to be
more public about than we already have
been I think we've been very public
about it uh or that uh you know uh you
know we need to smash down on the
accelerator here the discussions are
going well uh we think uh and uh we
strongly believe that a price cap is is
a good approach uh the right approach to
uh to limit Mr Putin's ability to
profiteer off this war
um and uh our EU colleagues are working
through the modalities are at right now
how that would be implemented what level
it's going to be at we think those
discussions are going on in a pretty
robust fashion so I don't think we
believe there's a pressure on us right
now to get more involved than we already
are
sent by the leadership of Five News
organizations to the administration one
of those organizations is the New York
Times these organizations worked with
Julian Assange prior to the publication
of classified cables by Wikileaks and
they're asking that the administration
dropped the Espionage Act charge that
was put forward against Assange by the
Trump Administration generally what's
the White House's response to that
request and I'll start there in the last
Republic yeah we're aware of it and we
would refer you to the justice
department all right uh anticipating
that answer what is it your assessment
or what is the National Security
council's assessment of the farm that
was done by the Wikileaks leak in 2012
and that would inform any decision to
find a Justice Department I I think you
know we if you go back and look at how
the administration responded in 2012 and
of course
President Biden was then vice president
at the time uh we would uh we would
maintain that we that what what we said
at the time what was said at the time
that uh that those uh that those leaks
those revelations in the public sphere
were damaging to U.S national security
yeah I just wanted to ask
um the head of NATO is warning that
essentially Vladimir Putin is using
winter as a weapon of war against
Ukraine What specifically is the United
States doing in conjunction with this
partners and allies to counter that
given the continued attacks on the
energy grid so you're referring to his
targeting of Civilian infrastructure
yeah so I mean this is a guy who's used
food as a weapon
um he's used fear as a weapon
um he uh in uh as a
as our as the Secretary General NATO
said now he's he's using the the coming
cold weather uh here to basically try to
bring the Ukrainian people to their
knees let me take a look at what he's
hitting it's almost all civilian
infrastructure uh and it's largely as
you pointed out it's energy it's water
it's the kind of resources that people
need as they get ready to brace for what
will no doubt be a cold winter
um and um so what we're doing is a
couple of things first of all uh we're
still going to continue to provide the
Ukrainian Armed Forces with the tools
weapons the capabilities the training
that they need so that they can be
successful on the battlefield and they
have been
very successful in just the last few
weeks secondly we're working with allies
and partners uh around the world and
certainly working inside uh the various
agencies of this Administration to get
spare parts equipment Transformers uh
you know the kinds of material they'll
need to get some of these systems and
networks back up and running and get the
power turned back on uh in much of
Ukraine as well as of course Water
Resources so we're working on that very
very hard again with allies and partners
it's some of the material will no doubt
come from the United States
but we also recognize that their grid is
is based on uh on uh infrastructure that
is uniquely European uh and so we're
gonna we're working with again allies
and partners in the region as well to
see what they can do to to get uh to get
more in there to keep the lights on and
the water running uh but it's despicable
it's absolutely despicable what he is
doing uh in these last few weeks not
that it hasn't been despicable before
but you you hit exactly on the issue
that these targets are largely civilian
and it's designed to one for one reason
and that's to to try to bring the
Ukrainian people to their knees because
he can't bring the Ukrainian Armed
Forces to its knees
um and you would think that now going
into I guess it's eight months now which
is hard to believe actually going into
our ninth month here
um that uh
that he would have learned he Putin
would have learned a while ago that you
just can't bring the Ukrainian people to
their knees
[Music]
thank you Peter the most powerful
nuclear force you sort of expect Ed to
uh conduct a nuclear test in the near
future we've said that uh we believe
uh Kim could conduct a nuclear test at
any time
yeah just
keeps this month
why
why I certainly can't speak to the
parenting skills of Kim Jong-un I'm
afraid I don't have anything for you I
look uh in all seriousness uh the man
continues to advance uh military
capabilities that continue to
destabilize the region not just the
peninsula but the region and we're
taking this seriously which is why we're
improving our intelligence capabilities
there collection capabilities in the
regions while we're working so hard with
Japan and South Korea bilaterally and
trilaterally the president had a chance
to meet with both leaders while we were
at the G20 to advance our own defense
capabilities and our own defense needs
people sometimes forget I've said it
along you guys probably roll your eyes
when I say this because I've said it
before but five of our seven treaty
alliances concerns since we started the
briefing talking about alliances 507
are in the indo-pacific and we take them
seriously because they put on us very
significant security commitments to help
with the defense of Japan and South
Korea respectively in this case and we
take that seriously which means we got
to make sure we're ready uh for the
kinds of capabilities that he clearly is
so interested in in continuing to pursue
[Music]
Greiner is being held
um uh it's indicating that she
potentially is exposed to forced labor
and homophobia and racism is there any
update about her physical and mental
health and I know CIA director Burns did
me with uh his counterpart in Russia are
there any plans to have another meeting
between officials between U.S and Russia
to specifically discuss this
negotiation to get her home great
questions both of them uh on the on the
second one we continue to have
ongoing conversations with Russian
officials about
Britney's release as well as Mr whalen's
uh and trying to get them home to their
families where they belong I can assure
you that those conversations are ongoing
um and uh we want them both home as fast
as possible and this Administration is
going to stay committed to that task
on her condition I I think you can
understand for for privacy Reasons I'm
not going to get into much detail about
uh her physical health I wouldn't do
that I can just tell you that we're
taking that very seriously as well
knowing where she is and what penal
colonies are designed to do
um and we're we're trying to make sure
we have as much uh access uh and
information about her condition as
possible
um sometimes that's done more through uh
her Representatives than it is
from our diplomatic presence just
because of the modalities of it but
we're doing the best we can to stay on
top of it as much as we can
president to attend the three Amigo
Summit in Mexico City I know that had
been talked about as potentially
scheduled for December now maybe pushed
back to January
Summit uh yeah um the president's
looking forward to uh to being able to
have uh to have that meeting
um but we don't have a date yet or
anything to say on the schedule nothing
to confirm on the schedule right now but
but he's looking forward to the
discussion absolutely
all right all right thank you thanks
guys Happy late Thanksgiving
thanks John
okay uh before we dive into questions
just to have a couple things a few
updates at the top to share with all of
you uh as you know President Biden
committed to doing everything within his
power to address Putin's price hike at
the pump uh today gas prices have
returned to the levels they were prior
to Putin's invasion of Ukraine as the
chart behind me shows the national
average is 3.55 cents per gallon down
over a dollar 45 cents uh per gallon
from the June Peak the most common price
is 299 per gallon that's saving uh
American families with two cars about
160 dollars per month on average this is
important breathing room for American
families and meets a key commitment the
president made to them so it's no
accident either on a couple of things
President Biden has been releasing oil
from the reserve as you know which was a
historic action that this president took
he called on International Partners to
release oil as well and he's been
calling on oil and gas companies to pass
on their savings to Consumers at the
pump
the president's actions have helped
bring prices down for families and he
will continue to do everything possible
to bring prices down even further
earlier today the president signed a
presidential memorandum on promoting
accountability for conflict related
sexual violence to strengthen the U.S
government's effort to combat rape as a
weapon of War
this presidential memorandum directs the
state department Treasury Department and
other Federal agency to leverage
sanctions authorities assistance
restrictions and other tools to promote
accountability for perpetrators of
conflict related sexual violence with
this executive action U.S departments
and agency are for the first time ever
being directed to ensure equal
consideration of Acts of conflict
related sexual violence when identifying
targets and preparing designations for
potential sanctions under President
Biden's leadership the United States
will continue leading efforts to Rally
other nations and international
organizations to prevent and promote
accountability for acts of conflict
related sexual violence today's action
is part of the president's broader
commitment to work to address all forms
of gender-based violence
now finally today President Biden met
with three U.S winners of the 2022 Nobel
Prize Dr Caroline bertozzi who won the
Nobel Prize in chemistry Dr John clauser
who won the Nobel Prize in physics and
Dr Douglas Diamond who won the Nobel
Prize in economic Sciences the president
is restarting an important tradition
that just like just like he does for
winning sports teams as you have seen
him do in the past 20 months or so the
president meets with U.S winners of the
Nobel Prize their achievements show how
taking on the biggest questions can
establish new fields of inquiry promote
Technology Innovation and expand the
boundaries of what is possible their
work is a reminder of why president
often says that the America can be
defined by one word and you all know
that word that he uses as possibilities
um with that I'm gonna go out of school
for a second and I know there's a young
reporter in the room who would like to
ask a question Eva Eva Shapiro
sure oh Barbie and where are you from
Austin Texas and you are part of the
kids scoop all right well welcome to the
briefing room it's great to have you and
you could you're going to Trump AP and
I'll take your first question
um given the situation in Iran with
protesting what are we going to do or
what can we do today
so that's an excellent question and an
important question to ask and we have
answered this question multiple times
here at the at this Podium and the
president spoke to this uh when he uh
wasn't in the in the halls of the United
Nations not too long ago in September
and he said uh we stand with the brave
citizens and the brave women of Iran who
right now are demonstrating to secure
their basic rights end quote there's a
lot that we can do and a lot that we are
doing to support those Brave citizens
again of Iran those those Brave
protesters we're taking steps both on
our own as the United States and also in
partnership with other countries uh just
around the world and including
organizations like the United Nations as
I mentioned when the presidents first
made his comments about what we were
seeing in Iran from the civilians but
let me just give you a couple of
examples we're using economic tools like
sanctions against Iranian officials we
support the UN Human Rights councils
vote to create a fact-finding mission to
investigate human rights abuses in Iran
which which was really historic
something that we had not seen so we're
working with civil society organizations
to make sure Iran is removed from a
United Nations body focused on women
called the UN Commission on the status
of women we have expressed support for
the joint statement by women foreign
ministers on Iran and and we're speaking
out over and over again and raising
awareness and making sure that those
Brave women and citizens are are lifted
up as they are really fighting for their
basic rights but thank you so much for
your question I really appreciate you
and again welcome welcome to the
briefing room hopefully you come back
all right go ahead and welcome to the
briefing room uh on uh two and a half
weeks ago when the president held this
press conference after the midterm
results he said he'd be announced
inviting Congressional leadership with
both parties over the White House um
after his trip uh
week plus since he's been back has that
invite done out and when is that meeting
going to take place so as you know
Congress has just returned so the
president is looking forward to talking
to uh speaking with uh to uh Democratic
and Republican leadership I don't have
anything to preview for you at this time
on a date on when that will happen but
he is this is something that he is
indeed looking forward to and we will
make that happen as soon as we can today
is uh this deadline for counties to
certify election results in a number of
States including Arizona where at least
one County uh has refused to certify the
results of the midterm elections for a
couple weeks ago deciding to be conduct
of the election in another County in
Maricopa County uh does the White House
is the White House monitoring sort of
state level people in local county level
efforts to overturn election results or
not certified election results and does
the president have any response so the
very good question I don't have anything
to share on if we're monitoring anything
specific or in particular I'm sure
that's something the DNC is doing and
other committees are clearly focusing on
on those particulars very closely uh
it's been very clear on the sacred right
to vote and how
important that the American people feel
like their vote will be counted and that
and he has denounced uh the election
deniers that we have heard from on the
other side and he has called that out
and he has every confident uh in our
electoral system and lastly we know
those rail negotiations are seem to be
nearly impasse
there's a report of the Washington Post
the president plans to pass Congress to
step in and either extend the
Philadelphia talks or take some other
measures to try to prevent the potential
devastating shut down at the rail system
in the next couple of weeks does can you
confirm that the president does plan to
ask Congress to study to take action
here look I don't have anything right
now at this time to announce or preview
on any uh announcement that the
president's going to make once he is
ready to make that announcement
certainly he we will let you know or
make an announcement of any kind uh
related to to this we will clearly share
that with all of you I do want to say a
couple of things which is really
important as we look at what's currently
happening look from the beginning the
president has been very clear shutdown
is unacceptable because of the impact
that it would have on jobs and families
and farms and businesses and communities
just across the country the president is
directly involved in the process and has
been engaged with his team and uh also
has have conversation with members of
Congress on this particular issue in
case in case resolving the issue in case
of resolving the issue Falls to them as
it has 18 times in the last 60 years as
as you know I know you guys are
following this closely and in addition
in addition to president's involvement
secretary Walsh has been in contact with
rail workers the unions there he has
been in direct connection contact with
them secretary Buda judge has been in
contact with rail companies and
secretary vilsack has engaged
Agriculture and Industry stakeholders as
well so this has been uh very much not
just the president but clearly the three
secretaries that I just mentioned and
his administration a majority of unions
as you all know have voted to ratify uh
the uh the temporary agreement that's
eight out of 12 there are 12 unions
involved and the best option that we
believe that the president believe is
still for the parties to resolve these
themselves the resolve this themselves
and to do this uh really in short order
um members of the Democratic National
Committee are meeting here in Washington
later this week to talk about the
potential calendar for the party's
presidential nomination process in 2024
. they're doing this in essence at the
behest of the president who has
signaled that he's not a huge fan of
Iowa going first given the lack of
diversity in that state can you say
whether he intends to weigh in on this
issue as or before they meet
or if he indeed believes that Iowa
should lose its first in the nation
status so look this is not something
that I'm going to speak to from here
this is something that the Democratic
National Committee as you know is that
committee that you're speaking of is out
of the DNC and so I would refer you to
them specifically I don't have anything
else to preview or to share about any
comments or statements that the
president may make on this particular
issue but again from here I'm not going
to comment from on this I would refer
you to the to the to the DNC
[Music]
are there any plans for the president to
go to Georgia in the final days of the
Senate runoff so I I've been asked this
question before about what the president
is is uh could potentially be doing uh
for uh the Georgia runoff I have to be
careful because it is an existing uh
existing race that is happening and so I
cannot I am covered by the Hatch Act so
can't speak uh specifically to this but
what I can say and I've said this before
the president is is willing uh to do
whatever is needed of him uh by uh
Senator Warnock I don't have anything
else to preview from here so does that
mean that the ask hasn't been made from
Senator Warner I really I just I don't
want to dive into
request or ask that something that we
didn't do during the midterms uh the
past several months so certainly not
going to start now what I can say I
don't have anything to preview for you
at this time or to announce but again
the president is willing to do whatever
is asked of him the Boston Globe is
reporting that the president is
in on Friday for a fundraiser can you
confirm that trip and then also with a
note that that day the Royals will be in
Boston as well for the Earth shot prize
because they're potentially going to be
an overlap or meeting so we heard about
that this is the the Prince of Wales is
going to be
um so um
I I don't have anything to share uh on
the president's travels uh for any
traveling announcement to make uh for
Friday or um uh any any future date
after tomorrow as you all know he'll be
going to Michigan uh once we have
something to share certainly we will
share that and as as far as the the
Royals being in town I don't have
anything to preview as well
I'm talking about uh answering a
question about this specifically in
Nantucket and he said he would do the
rest before the end of the year what did
he mean by that and then we'll be here
you'd be going to Walter Reed as he did
last year that's a good question I
haven't I actually have not talked to
him about that I remember him saying
that over the weekend look I I was asked
this question uh just at the last
briefing you know the president is in
good health and maintains an active
lifestyle you see him on a almost on a
regular basis yourselves and you can see
he always says watch me uh he will have
a physical in the upcoming months and
the results will be certainly released
as the same way it was last year in a
very transparent way and we will be
sharing with that with all of you as
soon as as soon as we have it good
Stephen thanks just to go back to the
rail labor dispute well what would drive
the president to seek Congressional
resolution here look I'm not going to
legislate from here uh what I can say is
we have been in regular communication
with Congress for the past several
months but certainly not going to
legislate or or lay out a process from
here
ask you this in 1992 the last time
Congress intervened to prevent a labor
rail shut down
senators and only six to say that the
Congress should not intervene that it's
a dynamic that favors the railroads
against the interests of the workers why
would he seek Congressional intervention
now look
again I can't I'm I'm when the president
has made a decision on this if he makes
a decision on this you'll hear directly
from him don't have anything to share or
preview at this time as I mentioned
moments ago the president has been in
regular contact with members of Congress
he has been directly involved in having
those conversations directly involved
with his administration I laid out what
secretary Walsh is doing with secretary
Buda judge and secretary vilsack this is
something that has been a priority for
this President and this Administration
for the past several months majority as
I just laid out also moments ago of
unions have ratified the tentative
agreement again I'm not going to
legislate from here I'm not going to get
into get ahead of any potential
announcement but as you stated in in
cases like this issues Falls to Congress
and it has done this 18 times in the
last 60 years so again it's not unusual
but I'm just not going to get into a
hypothetical from here at this time okay
a couple questions about the lame dark
agenda the the president said last week
that he was going to try to ban assault
weapons during this session what does
that look like is he making calls is he
taking meetings on this is he task the
team with working on this and does he
think that 60 votes are actually
possible here that's within reach
somehow so I'm so glad you asked the
question Mary because this morning when
I was in the Oval Office in a meeting
with the president he actually brought
this up himself because he knows how uh
his comments were reported over the
weekend and he wanted to be very clear
and he said that you know he believes
that it's important to keep this issue
in Banning assault weapons at the front
of minds of Americans he believes that
it is up it is it is also up to him as
president of the United States to make
the case for why it is critical to move
forward with assault assault weapons ban
and so he he look uh he understands
what's at stake he wants the American
people to continue to understand what's
at stake we know men any communities
have felt this very deeply very
personally and he also believes you know
there were families this past this past
Thanksgiving holiday who looked around
their table and there were missing
members of their family because of this
gun violence this horrific gun violence
that we have seen as recently as this
weekend as recently as just last week
and he believes that they deserve they
deserve to for us for him to continue to
talk about this continue to put this out
there
about the importance of getting this
done for American communities but again
look we understand it's an uphill battle
we understand that this is not easy he
gets that but doesn't mean that he's
going to stop fighting for it or that
he's going to stop talking about it and
one other issue raising the Dead ceiling
we've seen Republicans sort of
threatened to use this as leverage to
get some of their agenda items through
how much importance does the president
place on raising the debt ceiling during
a lame dive session so look you know uh
we've been clear about this when it
comes to uh the debt ceiling it should
not it should not be used or or never be
a matter of political brinksmanship
we've been very clear about that and you
know Congressional Republicans they
passed this uh with the last president
three times the former president they
they passed to lift the debt ceiling
three times there's no reason why this
should not be uh happening this time
around though Congress you know needs to
take the responsibility once again to
address the debt ceiling before it
expires and they need to act sooner
rather than later look now that Congress
is back we we believe that uh you know
there will be more of an urgency to get
this done uh and look this is this is
about um you know the sooner they act uh
you know this is about our economy this
will be better for our economy so we
have those conversation the president as
I was asked moments ago is going to meet
with leadership uh from both the how uh
from both the house and the Senate the
Democratic and Republican leadership and
uh and certainly we'll be having these
conversations
the gas price prices are back down to
levels before the war housing prices on
the other hand are not coming down
nearly fast enough
given the split Congress and you know we
talked about some of the difficulty of
the lameback session I mean have you run
out of options in terms of pressing down
depositing prices and what can you do to
help people there especially if the
student debt issue doesn't you know go
your way look we are as the president
said to your to your last statement
about the student debt relief his relief
plan he's optimistic he's an optimistic
person and he's going to continue to
fight for a plan that's going to help
close to 40 million Americans across the
country and let's not forget 90 of them
are making less than seventy five
thousand dollars a year that matters
that is a plan that is going to give
people a little bit of breathing room so
we are we are confident in our uh in in
our in our legal standing if if you will
as you know it's it's up it's up to the
Supreme Court and uh we're going to
continue to fight that it will not end
uh but to your question look for a
housing affordability is a central
challenge for families uh we know that
as you just laid that out Andrea and
that's due to long-standing shortfall of
affordable housing plus increased demand
for homes during the pandemic and a
reduced number of homes due to previous
supply chain challenges so the good news
is this that we are starting to see the
housing market cool by a range of
measures just a bit several data sources
now show that rent falling are or rent
growth easing in recent months which
should mean lower shelter inflation on
on months ahead and but we understand
and we get it as I just said it's a
central issue for many families and many
many Americans there's more work to do
and we will continue to uh to uh to use
all of the administrative tools to make
sure that we give we continue to give
families some relief the question about
Twitter
um you know there's the researcher at
Stanford who says that this is a
critical moment really in terms of
ensuring that Twitter does not become a
vector for misinformation I mean are you
concerned about
the you know
Elon Musk says there's more and more
subscribers coming online are you
concerned about that and what tools do
you have who is it at the White House
that is really keeping track of this so
look this is something that we're
certainly keeping an eye on and uh look
um we you know we have always been very
clear
um and that when it comes to social
media platforms it is their
responsibility to make sure that when it
comes to misinformation when we when it
comes to the hate that we're seeing that
they they take action that they continue
to take action again we're all keeping a
close eye on this we're all monitoring
uh what's what's currently occurring and
we see you know we see it with our own
eyes of what you all are reporting and
just for for ourselves what's happening
on Twitter but again social media
companies have a responsibility to
prevent their platforms from being used
by any user to incite violence
especially violence directed at
individual communities as we have been
seeing and the president has been very
clear on calling that out he'll continue
to do that and we're going to continue
to monitor the situation go ahead thanks
I don't think the president has spoken
to the house Republican leader since the
day after the election even though the
house was called for Republicans a few
days later is there anything you do with
the fact that he may not actually be
speaker of the house next Congress or
how are you guys kind of working through
that but no I I that I mean Congress has
been out they're just coming back in uh
look the president has been really clear
and he's underscored this many times
that he's eager to find common ground
and work across the aisle that is
something that he has done while he's
been president here at the chips and
science act as you you all know the
bipartisan infrastructure law is
something that he's been he's done as
well and he has signed into law more
than 200 pieces of legislation that were
bipartisan so look he's looking forward
to having those conversations with
Congressional Republicans and uh and and
what his focus is and he's been very
clear about this is delivering for the
American people continuing to give them
that little bit of breathing room and
once we have that meeting set we'll
certainly we'll share that and then when
it comes to the land duck you talk about
the bipartisanship idea he's going to
need at least 10 Republicans on a
government spending package if an
Omnibus is going to move forward has he
been given any signals by Senate
Republican leadership that there will be
10 Republicans for an overarching full
fiscal year deal so look when it comes
to the government funding uh you know
our efforts uh to secure the needed
Government funding are in good hands
with our OMB director Shalonda young she
is not new to this as you know she did
we we were able to get this done in a
bipartisan fashion just last year and so
she knows how to reach across the aisle
and so we are confident that we will get
this done and you know we have been our
office of ledge Affairs the office
office
OMB as well has been in has had multiple
calls with Congressional members and
staffers and also have done briefings
about how important it is in reaching an
agreement a full year Appropriations
agreement and the dangers of passing the
buck yet again and and not only that I
think you all saw just last night the
Secretary of Defense secretary Austin
put out a letter he wrote to Congress
and he said he said he warned that A
continuing resolution of any length
would result in significant harm to the
American people military programs and
our national security and our
competitors we have to remember the
programs that we're talking about are
not partisan programs there are programs
that's going to help American families
we're talking about education we're
talking as I just mentioned as the
secretary said our national security uh
you know we're talking about things that
really truly matter to the American
people education Cutting Edge technology
all of these things are not are not
partisan issues and so we should be able
to get this done in a bipartisan way
just like we did last year
you mentioned earlier about how passing
an assault weapons ban would be an
uphill battle especially given the
breakdown in Congress I wonder if there
are other things the president is
considering whether it's executive
Authority or calling Governors to take a
look action at the state level what are
some of the other things that are the
president's considering well so let me
just first state I get your question but
let me just first state a couple of
things number one this president has
taken more executive action his first
first year and a half on dealing with
gun violence and any other president and
that shows his commitment and what he
has been able to do and and wanting to
make sure to protect our communities and
so just want to be very clear on that
and let's not forget just a couple of
months ago there was a bipartisan
legislation uh on on protecting our
communities to to Really deal with the
effects of gun violence and so that is
something that happened that was the
first time we were able to see that type
of legislation in 30 years so again I
have said this the president is an
optimist but he also understand that it
is he sees that is as his responsibility
to continue to make the case I don't
have anything else to preview as as to
any additional executive action that
will be taken from here but again we
have seen action on this during his
presidency that we hadn't seen in 30
years
question about
you have a preview on the what he plans
to to say and sort of what that pretends
for his future travel uh during the lame
duck and
yeah I actually do I have something to
share for you all to preview
so as you just mentioned the president's
going to be going to Michigan
specifically Bay City Michigan to
discuss the American manufacturing boom
thanks to his economic strategy the
president will visit a mat a new
manufacturing facility recently opened
by SK siltron which last year announced
a 300 million dollar expansion of its
Michigan operations during his remarks
President Biden will highlight his
economic plan it is leading to a
manufacturing boom growing the economy
and creating good paying jobs in
Michigan and also just across the
country as well as you all know the
economy has created more than 700 000
manufacturing jobs and that is 10
million total jobs created under this
president in his first uh almost two
years here in in the white house he will
also discuss Democrats success in the
midterm elections in Michigan Thanks to
our efforts to build an economy from the
bottom up in the middle out to protect
democracy as you've heard the president
speak to and protect women's
reproductive health care which is the
something that the president and the
vice president is committed to doing I
would expect more uh coming from us this
evening we usually do a background call
or have some information out there for
you all to just lay out exactly what you
can expect from from the trip okay
on the rail issue again uh you know when
this was the tenant of the grant was was
announced a few months back it sort of
LED it was after what an hours-long
overnight meeting with all of the
parties involved with the labor
secretary the talks reached that level
of intensity that level of Engagement
with the administration and if not is
that a strategy we would see employed
again essentially putting all of the
parties in a room overnight however long
it takes and nobody leaves until there's
a deal no totally uh appreciate the
question look the president has been
very clear shutdown will be unacceptable
as I mentioned secretary Walsh has been
in direct contact with the unions uh the
real unions uh secretary Buddha judge
has been in touch with the rail
companies and uh and secretary vilsack
has been in touch with the agricultural
sector so we have been in regular touch
with folks and we're continuing to do
that the president has had multiple
conversation has been directly involved
with his administration and also members
of Congress and so what we believe and
what we will continue to say is that we
think and and what should be happening
in good faith is that they should come
up with a solution and majority of the
unions have ratified this you have eight
out of the 12 which is important to also
note uh but again this is uh I'm just
not going to get into any details on on
what else uh we can other efforts that
we might be taking it's been planned or
set with every every representative I
don't I don't have I don't have anything
to preview about convening everyone here
all at once but it matters it matters as
secretary Walsh has been in direct
contact with the rail workers it matters
that secretary Buda judge has been in in
touch with the companies and it matters
for certain that secretary vilsack has
been in touch with the agricultural
sector and that's going to continue
those conversation uh will continue to
happen again the president has been very
clear a a shutdown is unacceptable it
will hurt families communities across
the country it will hurt jobs it will
hurt Farms it will hurt businesses and
it just should not be happening
one question
sympathy to the Dominican Republic
issued a warning to U.S citizens about
those traveling to Dr that those that
are dark-skinned were being targeted
this as Dominican Republic is doing a
more deportations of patients and so my
question is is there anything that any
response or actions from the
administration in light of this warning
that's come out so when it comes to the
warnings that comes from the secretary
of state so I would refer you to them on
the specifics and the particulars of
that of that warning and would just let
them speak to it themselves
I just want to ask a quick follow-up the
president has said repeatedly that of
course he wants to ban assault weapons
but on Thanksgiving uh when he was in
Nantucket he said quote the idea we
still allow semi-automatic weapons to be
purchased is sick obviously that's a
huge category of guns from rifles to
pistols to shotguns that are not assault
weapons so I guess my question here is
did the president misspeak or does he in
fact want to ban all semi-automatic guns
no he was he was talking about uh
assault weapons that's what he was
talking about on that on that morning or
that afternoon when when he was asked
that question thank you okay all right
good again uh as you know former
president Donald Trump uh had a dinner
with Kanye West and Nick Fuentes a known
white nationalist does the is the White
House concerned that a former president
and more importantly a current candidate
or president is uh meeting with someone
known to Foster racist anti-semitic
abuse so look I'm I'm not going to
respond to everything that happens with
the former president but this this is
something that's important that we speak
very clear about and we speak very very
forcefully about this Administration
this President totally rejects uh
bigotry racism anti-Semitism and there
is just no place for these types of vile
forces in our society and this is
something that we are going to continue
to deny including Holocaust deniers and
let's not forget when you say things
like this when you
um when when you do not speak out
against these type of poisonous and
dangerous uh kind of remarks or a
representation if you will that is that
is also uh incredibly dangerous within
itself and so we need to we should all
be condemning this and we should be very
clear very clear and say it in in really
absolute clear terms and again this is
something that we condemn and we will
continue to speak out against
mine or the kind of rainbow flag and
wearing a t-shirt saying free on a
rather respect for Iranian women ran
across the pitch and you know was then
taken away
um so first of all is the president
going to be I know he's traveling
tomorrow and he's got a good speech and
so but it's right around the time of the
uh the game is he going to be is he is
he going to be basically Captain breast
of you know how that's going and just on
the political side uh what does he feel
about the rights of people to do things
like what this man did just now uh
waiver wave of LGBT flag and call out
for Iranian women just more broadly and
um you know we'll say this look we we
urge the state of Qatar and all qataris
to fully realize the amir's message here
and that that is to truly uh uh
recognize uh and and welcome everyone to
the cup to the World Cup and we've been
very clear about that we have said that
many times before we are concerned of
over the potential treatment of lgbtq
plus Spectators and athletes and uh and
you know this is something that the
president will call out any type of
human rights abuses uh he is he is not
shy and has been very clear raising
these issues uh and uh and he'll
continue to to do that and look when it
comes to the game tomorrow clearly the
president will be kept kept abreast of
how that particular game is going but as
you know we will be going we'll be
traveling to Michigan tomorrow all right
thanks everybody
foreign